Skrattar du förlorar du Youtube's favourite show! That's right they have a lot of foo- they lock my videos
Today we're giving away an Xbox and my Pokemon collection
Just make sure you leave a like on this video
Smash the like and a bell ring and
Then you could win all of these three items at some point
All you have to do is not laugh in this video guys. The rule is simple
You laugh, you lose. Skrattar du förlorar du, mannen
What do you think Donald Trump needs to do to come out on top?
Well, on the character issue the public, you know, two-thirds or more of the public knows that Hillary Clinton's a liar
She can't be trusted and now the two faces of Hillary Clinton are coming out, the fact through WikiLeaks that she says one thing. Oh,
*BEEEEeeEEp*
Oh no, alright, let's see if we can get congressman Collins back. Obviously we just lost the satellite feed. That sucks :(
*Pewds bootyful laugh*
WHAT
I'm sorry. What? Is this real? Oh no. Aw bad. Damn. Oh, what a bummer
We just lost the satellite feed just like that happens. Aw man, happens at the worst times, doesn't it?
*bEEEEEeeeeP*
Ohhh nooo, alright let's-
Oohhhh noooo, *laughs*
Oh no, we demonetized all of PewDiePie's videos pfft that sucks. * cutie Pie's laugh*
Oh noooo, all these videos lost all these revenue :(( we're gonna try our best to get it back up. Pfft, that sucks
*robot noises eeeeeeeee*
*WaPOW*
WOAH
*more robot noises*
*laughs*
(watched this it was a good laugh)
00f that cracking noises tho ouch
Oh my god
0uch
Just give it back to him >:0 . Oh my god. Thank you. Jesus
Goddamn, that was amazing
Clearly giving up on the Skrattar Förlorar in case it wasn't obvious ( What)
Just letting you know I am aware. Okay, I know what I'm doing. I just like to have fun
Plus I would like to win the Pokemon collection. That's right. I'm joining my own giveaway
all you have to do is leave a like, hit the bell button and
Tell your mother you love her ( Awww <33)
RUSSIAN: - Bread. *chuckles*
- Go on, go on, press it
Great, another Russian
- No, not this way, can't see it
*Squeky Pewds* I-It's not Russian, it's Ukrainian. 0k.
- Oops. *chuckles*
What is happening?
- Guess what, a loaf of bread
- Bread of the 21st century
- You can use it to wash yourself, you know?
Bread everybody, the top of comedy in Russia. You heard about this bread, huh?
You ever seen a bread??? That's hilarious
I've never seen anything funnier than a loaf of bread. That's all you need
Just give two grown men a loaf of bread and they'll never stop laughing
- Why, it's pretty normal (NO IT ISN'T)
- That's nuts
*confused pewds*
Why am I laughing? I'm so confused, what is happening? Can someone- uh, someone explain this one to me? Thank you
Thank you very much
'ASIAN KUNG-FU GENERATION - Re:Re:'
僕だけがいない街 [ERASED] Opening
Finally! Some real hood shit.
('Re:Re' continues playing) *pewds letting out his inner weeb uwu*
(I luv this song <33)
Okay, that was more of a You Groove You Lose but I guess, you know
- We're gonna give Bardio (?) his first hornworms
Ewww, oh no. Oh
What if he just makes friends with it
*sQueecKK
(Oh no!11! He's straight up animal planet)
(That looks so retarded (?) )
(*wiggling the worm wiggle wiggle wiggle ~*)
Shut up, he's trying to kill it man. Stop laughing this is really dramatic
*weeb song that somewhat fits this situation*
Marty else. It's not a paintbrush, buddy
*kawaii song continues playing*
I want you to look back at all the cute worms in that container and now that this is their fate xddd
Just eat it Bardio >:'00
Is it dead yet you *00f* idiot
*lizard continues swinging the unfortunate worm around while kawaii song continues playing ~*
I don't wanna do this anymore xddd
*\^0^/*
Alright It's been five minutes and he is still just painting
He's not a very good painter though :/// ( He will become one very soon)
Well now I want to get one (JusT eAt It BaRdI0)
This is the problem. Last- couple of You Laugh You Lose ago
We had a hedgehog and now we ended up with a hedgehog. So
No, no, I'm gonna say no on that one
(Awwwww man :'(( )
It's so cute tho <333
Oh my god this frickin game I'm so glad I'm done with this game
How long has he been playing?
Is that 12 hours no
00000oooooooOoo
That part sucks
O h N o
(FeelsBadMan :'(( )
U okay man :'( ?
:'((
No-ho. Oh he's losing it
*so much rage and sadness to the point he can't say anything *
* cries really hard on the inside while failing really uh ??? *
Is he making out with a chair?? ( what)
Korean manlets(?) everybody
They do exist (ca$h me ousside ) How about that
( Sorry never doing that ever again :'( )
Hold hold on chigu wiggu wiggu ~~
It's the Nazi pug dude. We found him. He escaped from jail ( 0h no)
- What the hell are you doing and who are you?
*pewds feeling the akwardness*
Oh my god, oh arghh
This gives me hope and faith because I realize I'm not the most awkward person in public Jesus Christ, dude
Oh my god
* Blend S mah dudes* Smile! Sweet! Sister! Sadictic! Suprise! ( best grill btw ;)) )
Guess we're still doing these huh ( smoke weed every day B))) )
00OOOhhH
OOOO00HHh Hell yeah
* BLEND W ( name of the song ) contiunes playing* ( Whoever made this you are amazing this is a masterpiece)
The effort Jesus ( IKR???)
Jesus Christ
YOO000OOOoooOO ???? THIS IS HIGH QUALITY
No, oh my god ( Yes bless this )
sm0Ke wEEd evEryDaY
That's incredible, Jesus Chri- MowtenDoo, I'll link that one in the description, that's incredible
Thank you guys for watching another episode of Skrattar du förlorar du, manneeeenn ;))
Have you guys joined the giveaway? Make sure I-I promise, it's not a fake giveaway
like all these other youtubers are doing, this is legit authentic giveaway. I want to give back to my fans
Which is one of you by showing, you know
By being so grateful. One of you will get one thing because I want to give back to all of you
By giving to one which I won't give for you. This is a scam. I'm telling you
It's a scam. You think I'm gonna give away my Pokemon collection? What are you, nuts?? Get out of here >;((
Get out of here !!11!!1! I'm saying literally get out >:00 ( Grrrr) The video is over. Goodbye
Everybody leave a like if you Skratta and leave if you Forlora and goodbye. Sayonara
It's been great. Why do I keep going? Can I end the video now? Thank you
Oh god, it's still going. Okay
( g0 !!!11! n0w !!111!)
Just gonna click stop